this is all that remains of nasser
mohelis's home in mikaela in northern
sudan the walls and roofs collapsed
after heavy rains and flash floods in
river now state leaving him and his
family with nowhere to go
we lost everything there's nothing left
we have to start from scratch we need a
lot of things food clean water tends for
shelter any kind of assistance we can
get we feel like we're being ignored and
it could rain again at any time
at least three thousand homes have been
damaged by the floods in mikaela this
week the government has declared the
affected areas disaster zones kalimat
anjali and her 16 year old daughter have
been sleeping out in the open after
their home was washed away she's
struggling to adapt to their new reality
we need food and something to drink but
we also need a concrete place to stay
our house is completely destroyed and we
use beds to make a shelter for my
disabled daughter from the sun and the
wind but the beds won't protect us from
the rains to come
the floods have also destroyed shops so
people can't replace their possessions
they've appealed to the government for
assistance
however aid is yet to arrive many of
these families have been relying on
donations of food and clothes from other
families the government has set up
emergency centers but those here say the
response is too slow
town's sewage system is damaged
prompting fears of an outbreak of
water-borne diseases
the damage to the sewage system is worse
than the shortage of food and water the
stagnant water will bring mosquitoes and
we don't have mosquito nets so we hope
the government sends health supplies to
prevent the outbreak of disease
more rain is forecast for the coming
days people here say without help the
already dire situation will only get
worse heber morgan al-jazeera michaelab
river now state